>> LIVE PICTURES OF A DRIVING
PROTEST IN ANNAPOLIS, MARYLAND.
AT THE CENTER OF THE CIRCLE
THERE IS THE STATE HOUSE.
WE’RE TOLD HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF CARS ARE GOING TO
DRIVE AROUND THE CIRCLE OF
PROTEST OF MARYLAND’S
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER.
THE GOVERNOR SAYS IT’S WAY TOO
EARLY TO OPEN UP IN THAT STATE.
THIS FOLLOWS A SIMILAR PROTEST
IN MICHIGAN THAT TOOK PLACE
EARLIER THIS WEEK.
AT LEAST FOUR SHERIFFS IN THAT
STATE, YOU CAN SEE THERE, PEOPLE
CAME OUT IN THE DRIVING RAIN,
THEY’RE SAYING THEY’RE NOT GOING
TO STRICTLY ENFORCE STAY-AT-HOME
ORDERS IN THEIR COUNTIES.
ONE OF THOSE TIM COLE OF MASON
COUNTY JOINS US.
WITH THOSE NOT FAMILIAR WITH
MICHIGAN GEOGRAPHY, PUT UP OUR
HAND OVER HERE ON THE RIGHT SIDE
OF THE COAST THERE ON LAKE
MICHIGAN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, SIR.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
WHAT OF GOVERNOR WHITMER’S
POLICIES AND ORDERS DO YOU FIND
MOST OFFENSIVE?
>> SO, I WOULDN’T SAY THEY’RE
OFFENSIVE, LELAND.
I WOULD SAY THAT IF I COULD JUST
GIVE YOU A SHORT BACK HISTORY.
YOU KNOW, VIRGINIA PASSED THOSE
SECOND AMENDMENT ISSUES AND LAWS
DOWN THERE AND WHAT HAPPENED
WHEN THAT TOOK PLACE IS PEOPLE
IN MICHIGAN KIND OF RAISED AN
EYEBROW AND SAID, BOY, WE HOPE
THAT DOESN’T HAPPEN HERE.
AND THEN THERE WAS SOME CHATTER
AROUND LANSING ABOUT SOME GUN
ISSUES AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
SECOND AMENDMENT SANCTUARY
COUNTIES STARTED POPPING UP ALL
OVER MICHIGAN AND IT REALLY DREW
A LARGE FOLLOWING AND ON THE
HEELS OF THAT THIS COVID MATTER
HIT AND THAT IS, OF COURSE, NOT
OUR GOVERNOR’S FAULT, IT’S NOT
ANYBODY’S FAULT, IT JUST
HAPPENED.
AND THE GOVERNOR ISSUED SOME YOU
KNOW, SOME ISSUES, SOME
EXECUTIVE ORDERS TELLING PEOPLE
TO STAY HOME AND PEOPLE ARE
ALREADY ON EDGE, YOU KNOW, OVER
THE SECOND AMENDMENT ISSUE AND
IT CREATES--
WE HEARD THE PRESIDENT TWEET
ABOUT THE SECOND AMENDMENT
ISSUES AS WELL.
WHEN WE GO THROUGH SOME OF THE
GOVERNOR’S ORDERS THAT ARE MORE
CONTROVERSIAL.
YOU’RE ALLOWED TO FISH IN A
CANOE, BUT NOT YOUR MOTORBOAT,
FOR EXAMPLE.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOUR
SHERIFF AND WATER OFFICERS WOULD
ENFORCE OR NOT?
>> IN OUR AREA, WE WOULD TAKE IT
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS.
WE--
IT IS AN ORDER THE GOVERNOR HAS
THAT YOU CAN FISH FROM A CANOE
OR A KAYAK, BUT NOT IN A 25
HORSE MOTORED DEEP SEA FISHING
BOAT.
>> DOES THAT MAKE SENSE TO YOU
AS A SHERIFF?
>> YOU KNOW, IT REALLY DOESN’T
TO ME.
I MEAN, IF I HAVE MY BOAT AT A
DOCK, BUT IT’S GOT A MOERT ONMOT
ON IT I CAN’T GO 40 FEET OFF MY
DOCK, BUT I CAN GO IN A CANOE IN
THE WATER AND POTENTIALLY TIP
OVER.
THOSE ARE HER ORDERS, I THINK
THERE’S ROOM FROM IMPROVEMENT
AND HOPE SHE’D UNDERSTAND.
YOUR PREVIOUS GUEST WAS SPEAKING
OUT OF DETROIT.
THAT’S A BEAUTIFUL AREA, BUT
WE’RE NOT DETROIT IN NORTHERN
MICHIGAN AND THE SOUTHEAST PART
OF THE STATE YOU CAN DRIVE FOR
MILES AND NEVER SEE A TREE.
IN OUR AREA YOU CAN DRIVE FOR
MILES AND NEVER SEE A HOUSE.
IT’S TWO DIFFERENT DYNAMICS.
LELAND: AS YOU POINT OUT, YOU’RE
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL, YOU’RE TO
UPHOLD THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN AND ENFORCE THE LAWS
AND THE VOTERS CAN SPEAK LATER.
THIS HEADLINE CAUGHT MY
ATTENTION IN "THE WASHINGTON
POST" WHICH DOES NOT NORMALLY
WRITE ABOUT MICHIGAN, BUT HERE
IT IS.
ALMOST EVERYBODY I KNOW IS OUT
OF WORK, HOW THE CORONAVIRUS HAS
UNLEASHED ECONOMIC HAVOC IN
MICHIGAN.
DO YOU SEE THAT ECONOMIC HAVOC,
NUMBER ONE.
AND NUMBER TWO, DO YOU WORRY IF
THINGS DON’T GET BACK TO NORMAL
AND PEOPLE AREN’T ALLOWED TO
RETURN TO WORK, DO YOU AS A
SHERIFF WORRY THERE ARE LAWS
YOU’LL HAVE TO ENFORCED.
>> MICHIGAN JUST PASSED THE ONE
MILLION MARK, UNEMPLOYMENT.
AND ONE OF THOSE WAS MY BROTHER,
HE HE WORKS CONSTRUCTION, HE WAS
OUT OF WORK BECAUSE OF THE
SHUTDOWN.
I DON’T TAKE ISSUE WITH THE
SHUTDOWN, BUT, YEAH, THERE’S A
LOT OF PEOPLE HURTING IN OUR
AREA.
LELAND: POTENTIALLY TO BE A
PROBLEM GOING FORWARD?
>> BEFORE WE WENT ON I WAS
LOOKING AT COMPLAINTS SINCE THE
ORDER HAS BEEN IN PLACE BY THE
GOVERNOR.
WE’VE ACTUALLY TAKEN EIGHT
CRIMINAL COMPLAINTS RELATED TO
THE GOVERNOR’S ORDER AND WE’VE
TAKEN 19 DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALLS
AND THAT’S HIGH FOR US IN OUR
AREA, THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CALLS.
LELAND: GOTCHA.
SHERIFF, WE’RE GOING TO HAVE YOU
BACK AS THIS GOES ON.
IT’S NOT OVER AND CERTAINLY THE
ECONOMIC HAVOC AND CATASTROPHE
IS NOT OVER.
WE APPRECIATE IT, SIR, I KNOW
YOU’RE LOOKING FORWARD TO SUMMER
UP THERE WHERE IT BECOMES GOD’S
COUNTRY RATHER THAN THE
BLEAKNESS OF THE GRAY.
WE APPRECIATE IT, SIR, ALL THE